non è che lo tampona un po un fazzoletto
per favore regia non c'è nessuna regia
sono da sola benvenuti in un nuovissimo
video
adesso non è che se siamo arrivati a un
milione ci fermiamo qua ragazzi
iscrivetevi al canale perché il prossimo
obiettivo sono i due fantastici come
leone
cliccate sulla campanella vicino al
tasso di iscrizione selezionando tutte
le notifiche per ricevere una notifica
tutte le volte che pubblicherò un nuovo
video oggi impostazione diversa perché
parliamo di beauty and make up
ogni tanto e gli amici di sephora mi
inviano tutte le novità da provare e
ogni volta che faccio l'unboxing nelle
storie instagram seno mi seguite su
instagram era arrivato il momento di
farlo cosa succede che ogni volta mi
dite sì ok barica però li fai vedere e
non li provi e fai un video in cui
propri perché sono che senso ha che ce
li fai vedere basta noi vogliamo sapere
di più quindi per la prima volta proverò
insieme a voi le novità che mi ha
inviato questo mese sephora ne vedrete
delle belle
dentro questa dossi sono sia dei
prodotti di make up ossia dei prodotti
beauty gel detergente scoli ente al
sabbia vulcanica c'è anche un vulcano
che sembra anche un brufolo spremuto
però ho questo tipo lo proverei
dopo questa cosa per questo fantastico
sia avviso allo zenzero io amo lo
zenzero in particolare un perfezionatore
della pelle e anche questo visto che
comunque sono un po truccata lo proverei
dopo adesso passiamo il make up abbiamo
una palette d'iseo chi che è super
carina guardate si apre come fosse un
agendina
qui ci sono le polveri per il viso qui
abbiamo volato un foglio di gli ombretti
quindi per gli occhi allora cosa
proviamo tutto e iniziamo con cosa
proviamo la terra vediamo questa qui
beswick carina
fate come me siete allo zigomo allora
dove la metti la terra io faccio una
sorta di tre vedete quindi parto dalla
fronte intensificò anche un po qui vado
a segnare lo zigomo e poi più volo via
verso il mento guardate un po non ho
l'illuminante perché ho aspettato a
metterlo visto che lo devo provare nel
video con voi e mi si crea già questa
fantastica zigo matar un po guardate poi
proviamo il blush che ci han su reach
sarà molto leggero devo dire io non amo
particolarmente le gote rosa quindi
perfetto per me e infine proverei
l'illuminante più chiaro che l'ultimo
questo qua tanto ve lo faccio vedere già
bello carico
beh beh lo devo dire stiamo neanche un
po sulla punta del naso
chi siamo per quanto riguarda gli
ombretti io mi ero già un po truccata
non ho messo il mascara perche appunto
lo devo provare con voi visto che mi è
arrivato un mascara nuovo e vorrei
utilizzare questo qui il secondo che
molto molto berlusconi
loro però solo in un occhio perché poi
ho un altro ombretto il liquido da
provare che anche molto brillanti noto
quindi ne troviamo uno per occhio
picchietto nella parte centrale della
mia palpebra beh devo dire super
differenza guardate un po approvato mi
piace questa palette devo dire valida
adesso passiamo al mascara il mascara
queste questo qui size up di sephora e è
però nella versione waterproof quindi
resistente all'acqua io avevo quello che
è uscito prima quindi quello normale di
solito il mascara waterproof non mi
fanno impazzire perché sono molto
grumosi hanno una consistenza più secca
diciamo meno liquida allora devo dire
che mi piace apre bene l'occhio in curva
le ciglia le divide bene ho provato mi
piace ovviamente bisogna testarlo con
tacco a caldo
eccetera eccetera speriamo di riuscire a
testarlo al mare quindi speriamo di
poter dare tutto e adesso passiamo
all'altro illuminante allora si chiama
3d glow ed è illuminante viso labbra
cioè non lo potete mettere un po ovunque
pd e mariners in ii magazine è
sicuramente è un faro nella notte o tira
consistenza e gel e molto acquosa
consistenza vado sono molto curiosa
ovviamente l'ho messo prima da questo
lato quindi tocca a lui
beh bomba considerando però messo poco
vai aumentiamo mentiamo l'intensità ok
ragazzi volete abbagliare la vostra
crush queste l'illuminante che fa per
voi
poi abbiamo
questo rossetto che si chiama ashta clip
stories ball ma vi chiedo a chi sta
facendo questa domanda ma io non so
perché pensavo fosse tipo un balsamo
labbra
cioè se non pensavo fosse così scuro è
tipo rosso mattone molto strong lo provo
a massimo quello leggo ho un po paura
per il contorno labbra da che sento lo
faccio prima con la matita soprattutto
per i rossetti più scuri ma questo
magari una consistenza più da burro
cacao va beh un bando alle ciance
proviamolo in che senso scusi o ok
cosa c'è che non quadra scusate cioè
rosso scuro comunque sia affermativo è a
tutti gli effetti un balsamo labbra loro
leggermente colorato diciamo che ravviva
il colore naturale delle labbra poi
abbiamo un eyeliner colorato proprio
fosse nero invece effettivamente è rullo
di tamburi
[Musica]
verde scuro che non mettete voi la verde
scuro si era tutti i giorni siccome per
ultimo lasciato un eyeliner molto
particolare adesso scoprirete quale non
me la sento di log on line è sicuramente
l'applicatore è il mio preferito per
quanto riguarda la eyeliner quindi molto
sottile a pennarello
facciamo una cosa proviamolo sulla mano
sicuramente scrive molto bene mi piace
non esce troppo prodotto quindi a
livello di prodotto top a e waterproof
proprio come il mascara quindi sarà
immagino una collezione per in vista
dell'estate con degli high line è un po
più particolare un po più estivi quindi
colorati waterproof
poi abbiamo loro due loro due sono degli
ombretti liquidi a parte il packaging
che molto molto stiloso degli ombretti
liquidi 1 mar
questo qui ovviamente è questo quickly
tesoro
inutile dirvi che sono innamorata di
quello glitter oro che non vedo l'ora di
provarlo ed è per questo che ho lasciato
un occhio tutto per te amore nearly il
pennellino è così quindi è simile a
quello di un gloss lo applico prima
sulla mano per vedere insomma di cosa si
tratta la consistenza e molto gelatinosa
come l'illuminante pensavo che avesse
più pagliuzze d'oro
secondo me anche come illuminante non è
malvagio ma proviamolo effettivamente
sulla nostra palpebra che ti amo con il
pennellino poi vado a fissarlo con il
dito allora un gel trasparente con dei
brillantini
come potete vedere questo da tutto un
altro effetto sinceramente preferisco
questo mi aspettavo qualcosa di più rock
e rivas gusti c'è a chi piace magari
proprio l'effetto shiny della palpebra
chi piace magari santo un tocco di luce
quindi può utilizzare questi qui
l'ultimo prodotto make up è senza ombra
di dubbio il protagonista
di questo video perché è una cosa che io
e credo anche voi non abbiamo mai visto
una novità una super novità una roba che
tu dici ma magia nera
ma bando alle ciance vi faccio vedere
subito di cosa si tratta voi lo guardate
lite vabbè che è un evidenziatore nero
ma con l'evidenziatore nero che cosa
sottolineate
ovviamente vi sarete accorti che ho un
occhio più truccato dell'altro e quindi
mi avete un po scoperta lo so anch'io
ero incredula quando io disse ma come è
possibile perché a tutti gli effetti
ragazzi guardate è un evidenziatore
hamel hanno inviato sia in versione blu
che versione nera ovviamente ho voluto
provare quella nera per quanto riguarda
questo occhio diciamo che ho dovuto
prenderci un po la mano perché la punta
è a tutti gli effetti quella di un
evidenziatore quindi non è la classica
punta a cui sono abituata dell'eyeliner
quella un po più sottile pennarello
sottile sottile
la cosa positiva è che appunto questa
punta un po particolare mi permette di
creare la codeina perfetta perché è come
se fosse uno stampino ne ho fatte due o
tre fino ad arrivare alla lunghezza
insomma che volevo per quanto riguarda
la codeina e avevo già mia codina bella
pronta ma bando alle ciance maria parli
troppo facciano vedere mettitelo datti
una mossa
come vi ho detto crea una mia codina
vedete se devo fare un appunto
effettivamente non non è sottilissimo
non saranno non otterrete mai una linea
sottilissima quindi se preferite cose un
po più
leggere forse non è liner che fa per voi
se invece vi piace comunque questo
effetto un po più marcato è perfetto da
meta codina unire ecco già fatto una
camera raw ente o sbagliato leggermente
ma poi la correggo con un cotton fioc
niente vado ad unire la codeina la rima
ciliare superiore e buona ecco qui
l'effetto finale devo dire che
nonostante l'applicatore un po diverso
dal solito mi è venuto anche abbastanza
bene bene effetto piace molto
devo dire mi piace davvero tanto
rimangono da provare questi due prodotti
quindi in gel esfoliante e il siero
nuovamente lasciato alla fine perché non
aveva senso usarli prima anche pelle
tutto granuloso effettivamente
spoglianti profumo ottimo mare e sabbia
vulcanica sabbia mare certo vulcano non
lo sento però mi piace mi piace alla
consistenza mi piace il profumo piace
molto come detto la consistenza fa
un'esfoliazione molto leggera con queste
micro sfere non è una roba aggressiva
vada sciacquarmi e tornò come potete
consegne dove mi sono struccata perché
rimane qua il fondotinta e questo
fantastico brufolo che mi darà primi
passi la sensazione di freschezza la
pelle rimane molto morbida prima di dare
la mia opinione per frey trovarlo
diciamo a viso pulito quindi senza
trucco per ora devo dire mi piace molto
ultimo prodottino che proviamo insieme
il siero allo zenzero 96 per cento di
origine naturale e normale e ragazzi di
solito quando un prodotto nuovo ci vuole
un po prima che esca però ecco non
vorrei passare la notte qui
eccolo ha schizzato tutto lo specchio
pantalone perfetto beh zenzero sari
zenzero l'odore è proprio serissimo e la
consistenza ovviamente un siero quindi
molto liquida anche questo da subito una
sensazione di freschezza
vediamo un po di freschezza e anche a
sto brufolo mi sembra molto leggero non
va ad appesantire la pelle c'è un siero
proprio molto molto leggero
ovviamente come tutti i seri poi dopo va
applicata la crema
direi che ci siamo eccoci arrivati alla
fine del video spero tantissimo che vi
sia piaciuto
fatemi sapere se vi piacciono video del
genere se volete vedere altri tre novità
che ha fatto iscrivetevi al canale ma
questo lo sapete già vi mando un bacione
e ci vediamo al prossimo video
adoro
ciao da me e dai miei nuovi amici
evidenziatori niente